miss kenichi on stage live with songs
from her latest album a style can best
be described as dreamed folk normally a
solo performer she appears on stage with
a band in her adopted hometown Berlin
miss kenichi suffers chronic stage
fright and this evening is no exception
Ganesa awesome biston I enjoy stage
fright a little to me it's just part of
what I do that's why I don't try so much
to get rid of it but rather to channel
it in the right way stage fright can
also help you stay alert and focused
she's brought in a high caliber
percussionist Earl Harvin drummer for
the British man tindersticks he's played
for such big names as seal and air and
his co-producer of Miss conoces new
album
as far as the audience goes she's passed
the live appearance test oh my god she
was amazing shoes I mean the whole thing
was just a spectacle music that man it's
the kind of music you like to hear when
you're driving just lying down looking
at the stars you can have to stand up
cook it has you floating on air like a
dream
miskin e cheese 2006 debut album
collision time was a fair-sized smash
one of her first songs was arrived
Katrine hana studied painting she
exhibits her works in galleries or uses
them for album covers once she had an
attack of painters block and started
playing guitar but she never took a
lesson she's been using her studio to
write songs ever since such a pleasant
surprise bandages item often on map have
it so much when I was recording the
album quite often I'd solve music
problems through pictures that puts my
mind into another zone and suddenly I
know exactly what to do in the other
discipline and the other way around when
I'm making music I'll often come up with
solutions for paintings where I'd gotten
stuck the latest single deals with one
of her pet themes the search for oneself
a song who are you was ideal as the
score of a now prize-winning German
motion picture drama it's a dark him
that leaves plenty of room for
interpretation
shinta shouldn't been I think it's
better when not everything has explained
and some things are kept in the dark
thinks you can only sense in a way
Kathleen Hanna moved to Berlin in 2006
she grew up in the Bavarian countryside
surrounded by nature and nature is one
of her primary sources of inspiration
now she's back in the forest at work on
a new video for her third album the
trail skipped subash Tim do lunch
off-speed there are certain landscapes
I've got in my mind that keep turning up
in my music sometimes it's an eerie
silence sometimes a soothing or a long
one but it always has to do with
countryside in nature Abbas hat tomorrow
vast Midland shaft or net worts a tune
backstage she's getting ready to go on
and here it comes again the stage fright
Adaline fluted the adrenaline is flowing
and happy I'm scared I'm all wound up
and at the same time I feel dead tired
all I want to do now is get started on
missed it I've had fun
when Miss kenichi plays in Berlin she
plays two familiar faces a new album is
due out in mid-november and she's ready
to take it on tour
you